let's have a look at these
together yeah okay all right
so um we are looking at these complex
numbers together we have taken
a number in i handed it to you in
rectangular or cartesian
form and then i've asked you to convert
it to exponential form and that was not
for no reason
it was so that you could perform these
operations right raised to a power
right do you have a question is it about
the answers here why don't should we
have a look at them and
we'll unpack okay so first one we're
looking at here z
equals minus one minus i and then we've
got of course in exponential form
two components that go into this right
is it reflective is that what it is
okay sure um we've got a modulus and
we've got an argument
actually this is ah i couldn't have
asked for a better segue i'm getting
ahead of myself
the modulus route 2 do we agree with
that
thumbs up it is because where do we get
that from it's in a
the modulus is the hypotenuse of a right
angle triangle
in this case it's a right angle triangle
with shorter sides one and one
one one root two thumbs up okay now the
argument up here
has been written as five pi on four and
in fairness i haven't said anything
about the way i wanted that argument to
be written
but i do notice uh five pi on four where
is
five pi on four if you haven't already
um draw yourself a little
complex plane and let's think about
where five pi
on four goes now five pound four
is more than pi now pi is a half
revolution
so there's pi and then how much further
do i go
i go pound four after that right hence
the five pound four
so therefore i'm going around a little
further so i'm heading in this direction
do you agree
does this match the quadrant that i
expect
based on reading rectangular form
it you should be nodding like i'm facing
in the right direction right
it's in the third quadrant minus one
minus i
however calling back and we haven't
spent a lot of time on this
calling back um to a previous lesson you
can clearly see this is
the scenic route isn't it we end up
facing in the right direction
but there is a shorter way there isn't
it what would be the shorter path
yeah it's it's going around this way
isn't it right we still end up facing in
the same direction
so what we're distinguishing between uh
the argument
or arguments i should say like in
addition to this i could have added 2 pi
still facing the same direction add 4 pi
and so on what do we call this one here
that's the smallest
angle has a special name we call it the
it starts with a p the say it again the
principle argument thank you so
in this case the principal argument
would be what would you say negative 3
pi on 4
negative 3 pi on 4. now i want to
strenuously make clear
these are the same complex number right
root 2 e to the 5 pi on 4 i and root 2 e
to the
negative 3 pi on 4 i are the same
complex number in exactly the same way
that for instance
this is the same as
this do you agree like those are not two
different things
different ways of writing the same thing
why do we like the principal argument
like why does it get its own fancy
looking name and that kind of thing
okay number one it does without having
to think about like how many times
around you have to go
it probably more efficiently tells you
what direction you're facing in
think about 2a and 2b and what i'm about
to ask you to do
why might the principal argument be
easier to work with
think like real basic guys like think
back to like u7u
and whether you had a choice of these
two to work with what would you do
it's just a smaller number right it is
it is the shortest angle there
which means it's going to be the
smallest value so when i
subsequently multiply by 2 or multiply
by 6
i just have to go not as far in my times
tables okay we will still get the same
answer but
let's have a quick look then at 2 a and
b i ask you to square it
so modulus i mean i i take slight issue
with how much this 2 looks like an l so
i'll just
fix it that's better okay modulus is
right happy with that
how about the uh how about the angle
minus three pound two is this the right
angle yeah well it is an argument that's
going to send us let's think about this
right
when you multiply a complex number two
things happen scale happens
and it's the other thing that happens
rotation right
so i've gone around this far i've gone
round clockwise
three point four if i go another three
point four clockwise
i'm at minus 3 pi on 2. that is the most
obvious way to double it right
however again if we think about this how
could we rewrite it with a principal
argument
2e to the
this is up here right so it's positive
pi on two do you agree
pi on two i we tend to write the i out
the front i theta but it doesn't really
matter it's fine okay
um are you okay with that is there an
even simpler and lazier way
to write this number there is right this
is
right on the imaginary axis it's on the
positive part no
real component whatsoever so we could
equally have written it in rectangular
form as
2i and as we keep saying mathematicians
famously
okay oh yeah uh last one here
eight's the right modulus am i getting
some nods some thumbs up happy times
okay
um 15 pi on two this angle is so large
because of how many times we multiplied
it didn't we multiply by six okay
can we find a principal argument that's
equivalent to this
i could write this as eight e to the
how do we do this what do you think
yes you okay with that um these are the
same the easiest way that i think about
this
is um e to the i theta is the same as
cos theta plus i sine theta that was the
whole point of euler's formula right
so the same periodicity that cos and
sine have
is the same periodicity that this has
right their period is 2 pi
so add 2 pi or subtract 2 pi until you
get to a nice
number um i guess i would have to
subtract
16 pi on 2. that would be the nicest
multiple that would get me to
here do you agree with that now just
like with the other one there's a super
easy lazier way of writing this
too this is minus or negative i should
say
eight oh yeah because this is facing
down in this direction
but i have to go all the way to um
negative 8i okay with that
wonderful